je me félicite mais vraiment tous les
jours qu'on ait pu avoir un vaccin aussi
rapidement
[Musique]
bonjour
autre titre de cette édition en Chine
mystérieux virus de la même famille que
le sera ça déjà contaminé 45 personnes
un chiffre beaucoup plus important selon
des scientifiques une épidémie qui
inquiète d'autant plus que le nouvel an
chinois approche le virus pourrait se
propager à l'étranger le 31 décembre
je vois arriver sur ma boîte mail
donc une de ces alertes qui nous dit
quatre personnes ayant fréquenté un
marché à Nancy se sont retrouvés
hospitalisés pour une pneumopathie
caractérisée comme atypique d'allure
virale qui n'était pas la grippe et là
il y avait plusieurs mots clés qui
étaient marcher pneumopathie atypique ça
n'est pas la grippe et la Chine qui nous
a évidemment rappelé ce qui s'était
passé en 2003 avec le coronavirus du
strass donc c'est quelque chose qu'on
suivait de près sans pour autant être
capable de de prédire la catastrophe qui
s'est finalement produite il y avait la
curiosité scientifique malgré tout de se
dire tiens un nouveau bêta coronavirus
très vraisemblablement la notion
d'urgence il faut agir extrêmement vite
pour ne pas se retrouver dans des
situations comme celles qu'on a pu
connaître avec le strass en 2003 mais
une inquiétude qui était malgré tout
pondéré par le fait que c'est des virus
que l'on connaît bien et que jusqu'à
présent on avait réussi à maîtriser
aucun d'entre nous n'avait imaginé que
le monde entier pouvait s'arrêter d'un
coup
ce qui est intéressant c'est de relire
les recommandations qui avaient fait des
experts de la grippe pour l'OMS en 2019
donc avant l'arrivée du Sark of 2
sur comment gérer une pandémie grippale
et il y avait toute une série de degrés
de sévérité et quand vous allez regarder
la ligne extrême et vérité à aucun
moment Iness suggéré par exemple de
confiner les populations chez elle moi
je me souviens avoir vu il y a peut-être
15 ans je me souviens plus exactement le
film contagion de Soderberg qui
m'avait frappé par
de tous ces films un peu catastrophes
sur des grandes épidémies ou pandémie
c'est celui qui je trouvais avec tapé le
plus juste sur la plausibilité du
scénario c'était dans le déroulé du film
et puis l'enchaînement qui suit
l'apparition des cas leur dissémination
des mesures prises par des gouvernements
puis la crainte des populations de se
retrouver
incapable d'avoir accès aux médicaments
ou au vaccin des émeutes etc reproduisez
ce que l'on pouvait craindre et redouter
d'une épidémie ou effectivement on se
sentirait tous individuellement menacé
et et où on se bat pour sa survie
[Musique]
visite surprise à Marseille à l'abri des
caméras officielles Emmanuel Macron à la
rencontre du professeur Raoul capté par
ces images amateurs le président est
venu prendre connaissance de ses
recherches contre le covid-19 car depuis
près d'un mois l'infectionologue mène un
essai clinique un traitement à base
d'hydroxycloroquine molécule dérivée
d'un médicament contre le paludisme
alors je me prononcerai pas sur des
questions politiques sur et des
motivations qui ont pu amener
Emmanuel Macron aller voir Didier Raoult
Didier Raoult était quand même une
sommité scientifique française
et à la tête d'un institut hospitalo
universitaire sur les maladies
infectieuses qui a pris des positions
très tôt sur cette épidémie où il
pensait finalement que l'impact ne
serait pas important il est au démarrage
toujours relativisé le nombre de cas par
rapport à la taille de la population de
la Chine par exemple et puis très tôt a
été convaincu que
l'hydroxychloroquine serait un
traitement efficace après avoir discuté
avec des collègues chinois il y a eu par
la suite des études qui ont été faites
par l'équipe de Didier Raoult qui avait
l'inconvénient de ne pas avoir ce qu'on
appelle nous un bras contrôle qui dans
l'approche de l'évaluation d'un
médicament et ce qui nous permet de
savoir ce qui se passerait en l'absence
de prise de médicament pour nous il
était essentiel que des études soient
menées avec un bras control pour voir si
l'hydroxy qui me faisait mieux que rien
si on mettait à placebo dans Black bras
control ou un autre traitement et c'est
ce qui est arrivé par la suite il y a eu
plusieurs études faites et notamment un
très gros essai en Angleterre à plus de
10000 patients ou contre un bras
contrôle l'hydroxygiène n'avait pas des
faits donc dans la communauté
scientifique on a compris à ce moment-là
que c'était malheureusement une piste
que on devait abandonner parce que il y
avait pas d'efficacité associé à
l'hydroxycloroquine ça a été d'ailleurs
une des déconvenues de cette épidémie
c'est que autant on a eu une excellente
surprise sur le vaccin qui est arrivé
beaucoup plus vite que ce que l'on
espérait autant sur les traitements il a
fallu attendre finalement le paxlovide
pour avoir un traitement efficace
bien sûr ce que je trouve que pour une
piqûre qui est très facile à faire ça
protège de maladies qui sont peut-être
dangereuses je suis en général pour les
vaccinations mais je suis contre le BCG
qui a provoqué certains accidents chez
des enfants d'amis à moi le BCG ma
petite n'a pas été vaccinée puis elle a
fait une primo-infection alors
maintenant toute la famille est vaccinée
moi y compris même le petit bébé je suis
tout à fait contre parce que je trouve
que ça fatigue les enfants et on vaccine
coup sur coup et je trouve que c'est pas
bon quand je réfléchis à la crise covid
je me félicite mais vraiment tous les
jours qu'on ait pu avoir un vaccin aussi
rapidement parce que deux confinement
supplémentaires en réalité nécessaire en
absence du vaccin la population
française n'ayez pas prête à faire ces
deux confinements de plus après
maintenant cette défiance elle a été
forte au début je pense que la France
était en Europe occidentale le pays où
le plus de personnes dizaines pas
vouloir se vacciner on est à 40%. et
finalement
on s'est on s'en sort plutôt bien je
crois qu'il reste à peu près 10% de
personnes non vaccinées contre la covid
alors je pense que ce que vous appelez
les antivax on est sur 5 à 10% de la
population dans les analyses qui ont été
faites sur cette population d'antivax on
retrouve des gens qui peuvent être pour
certains de façon tout à fait sincère
très inquiète des faits indésirables
mais que je pense à l'imagine mais qui
n'en sont pas documentés parce qu'on a
quand même notamment sur le vaccin de la
covid full d'études qui ont été faites
aucun vaccin n'a été autant étudié et on
connaît très bien aujourd'hui quels sont
les effets indésirables qu'on peut lui
attribuer mais bon voilà ces personnes
là ont une certaine défiance par rapport
à ce type d'études scientifique et puis
il y en a d'autres qui en revanche était
plutôt dans une posture un peu
contestataire et de méfiance politique
vis-à-vis du gouvernement qui je pense
que beaucoup d'études montrent
aujourd'hui que la confiance dans la
science ou la confiance dans le
gouvernement était très associ ée à la
vaccination et l'inverse donc
[Musique]
le médecin français lui a le vaccin et
tout ce que la science apporte chaque
jour déjà il a installé sa tente et tout
de suite ses mises à agir de 30-45 ans
de kilomètres parfois on est vu le voir
il conseille il soigne il vaccine le
rôle qui lui est passé est en effet
avant tout profites il convient surtout
de prévenir les maladies les infections
les épidémies alors les images qu'on
vient de voir me rappelle mon grand-père
maternel qui a fait partie de la
première promotion du Pharo qui est à
Marseille l'hôpital où était formé les
médecins qui allaient partir dans les
colonies je vois des images encore qui
nous étaient montrés de photos où il est
à cheval avec ma grand-mère et une
caravane derrière qui ressemblait à
celle qu'on voit dans les westerns avec
la bâche ou j'imaginais que les enfants
devaient se trouver à Madagascar partant
pour trois semaines pour trouver le
poste où il allait être basé et je ne
peux pas m'empêcher de me dire que voilà
quelque part c'est un peu imprégné mon
cerveau pour que plus tard j'ai eu envie
une fois que j'étais médecin de partir
moi aussi en Afrique et en Asie
travailler
[Musique]
le docteur Arnaud Fontanet du
département d'épidémiologie de
l'Université de Award étudie à coïdang
ces phénomènes de résistance on a à peu
près à 200 km ici du lieu où sont nés
les souches résistantes à la plupart des
antipaludiens dans le reste du monde une
alternative possible ce serait la
découverte d'un vaccin mais il faut
encore savoir de quoi on parle est-ce
qu'on parle d'un vaccin qui serait
destiné au tourisme ou aux voyageurs
internationaux qui vont dans les pays en
voie développement ou est-ce qu'on parle
un vaccin qui soit destiné aux
populations autochtones de ces pays
d'endémies mais qui devrait être un prix
modéré et qui ne devrait pas devoir être
répétée ce qui poserait des problèmes
logistiques considérables alors là je
retrouve je retombe effectivement à
kawidan qui est un des camps de réfugiés
cambodgien à la frontière entre donc
Thaïlande et Cambodge j'avais travaillé
avec Médecins Sans Frontières pendant 14
mois ça c'est le département des adultes
ou j'ai été effectivement basé et là
j'ai pris conscience qui avait ce besoin
de prise en charge avec des résultats
qui étaient spectaculaires que je
n'observais pas nécessairement dans la
pratique que j'avais en France en
rhumatologie et puis aussi la nécessité
d'une organisation des soins à l'échelle
d'une population j'ai commencé à
réfléchir et à me dire et si je ne
basculais pas plutôt vers la santé
publique dans le contexte des maladies
infectieuses tropicales en prolongement
de cette activité humanitaire qui
m'avait beaucoup plu mais avec un angle
de recherche et c'est comme ça que ma
carrière finalement a pris un virage
qui fait que je me suis retrouvé à
l'Institut Pasteur quelques années plus
tard
[Musique]
cette petite digue a une histoire
Lamartine venait s'y recueillir et c'est
ici à Brison-Saint-Innocent sur les
bords du lac du Bourget que Joseph
Fontanet a sa propriété de famille 50
ans ancien député centriste allié à la
majorité ministre du Travail en vacances
père de 5 enfants responsables de la
politique française de la population il
vit ici ces dernières heures de détente
avant le Conseil des ministres de demain
on voit sur les images oui je suis
l'enfant qui a 9 ans avec un pull marine
voilà alors ça c'était des moments pour
nous vraiment
privilégié où on récupère notre père
pour une ou deux semaines l'été
puisqu'il était donc au gouvernement à
l'époque un ministre de Georges Pompidou
il travaille énormément mais tout au
long de sa vie politique il a toujours
gardé une à deux semaines au mois d'août
alors il venait avec ses dossiers mais
il était présent avec nous et on pouvait
profiter de sa présence voilà faisant du
bateau et et des est-ce que font toutes
les familles quand elles sont en
vacances ensemble on baignait là-dedans
et c'est vrai que pour moi enfant
d'avoir eu l'exemple d'un homme qui
était toujours
très engagé dans
son combat politique pour améliorer la
condition des gens pour
il a été ministre de l'Éducation donner
travailler sur l'égalité des chances à
l'école etc forcément ça m'a marqué
[Musique]
hier soir à l'issue d'une conférence
économique à Viarmes dans le Val-d'Oise
Joseph Fontanet regagne seul au volant
de son véhicule une Renault 5 de couleur
foncée son domicile situé 36 boulevard
Émile-Augier dans le 16e arrondissement
à Paris il stationne son véhicule près
de sa propre porte d'entrée et
transporte son matériel de projection
dans son appartement au deuxième étage
il est un peu plus de minuit lorsque
Joseph Fontanet redescend il se dirige
vers sa Renault 5 pour fermer son coffre
à clé c'est alors que d'une voiture un
homme fait feu sur lui plusieurs balles
calibres 1143 la teigne dont une au
poumons puis sont ou 16 agresseurs
s'enfuit
on n'a jamais su qui était à l'origine
de cette attentat
à titre personnel je suis
je penche pour la thèse du crime fortuit
ça reste pour moi la thèse la plus
vraisemblable parce que mon père était
complètement retiré de la vie politique
à l'époque mon père était ce qu'il était
un homme simple engagé
extrêmement intègre il y avait cette
continuité dans le caractère de mon père
et son action qui sont restés absolument
intactes on en est resté du coup avec la
mémoire d'un homme exceptionnel qui elle
a continué nous accompagner
[Musique]
alors je choisirais plus volontiers à 5h
mais est-ce que vous allez m'organiser
cette interview
que tout ce qu'on dit là c'est bien
grave bien au stère est-ce que vous êtes
quelqu'un qui riait
alors oui je suis quelqu'un qui rit je
suis j'ai la chance d'avoir une famille
et des amis
nombreux j'aime beaucoup plaisanter les
exercices auquel je me livre aujourd'hui
est toujours difficile parce que je sais
qu'il faut que je fasse attention à ce
que je raconte les il reste des traces
de toutes nos
interventions et pour la postérité et
vos archives le montrent bien mais non
non je suis quelqu'un de
voir qui a une vie sociale riche et qui
aime beaucoup être entouré de familiers
d'amis